doing it in the back is your yeah
getting it done to me in the back the
back getting it from the back getting it
hard in the
[Music]
back welcome back to another exciting
episode of the careful boys where today
we get a little bit maybe opportunistic
that's the word we're thinking
opportunity okay here's the question
what was the best opportunity you ever
received what I know I got a good one I
was just talking about it I love the
quickness of that so I had uh it's cuz
it just like worked so I had a uh what
made me think of it is I had a intern
this week from my old high school as a
basketball player I played basketball my
whole life and so him and I are sharing
stories his coach was still my coach Etc
ET so we had a lot of TI in one of my
best opportunities that I [__] up cuz
I was an idiot 17-year-old uh I had the
chance and basketball was my whole life
I had the chance to um work out with a
guy who worked for Duke which is the
best best basketb program in the world
and he basically raided me uh on what I
need to improve etc etc to get to call
cuz you're trying to get to Pro the next
level yeah and obviously I knew I wasn't
like Duke level but he was at that level
so he could rev it all up so I work out
for him and he was like kind of a dick
but um he was like Stern with it you
know like hey man you got to work on all
this but he was real with it find out
later like 6 months later he recommended
my name and got me into like a Nike
Elite Camp which is actually made for
like allamerican level [__] and I wasn't
at that level but I I was good can you
dunk I used dunk but these are like the
pipelines where like like LeBron james'
kids Dwayne Wade's kids they would go to
these camps so they and the scouts are
already there and that's how you would
like kind of work especially back in the
day now there's aou which is little
there was aeou then but it wasn't as big
it was still a thing but Nike Elite Camp
was like it man like 200 best in the
nation and then I'm a knucklehead and if
you don't go to those you're not going
to the pros why didn't you go H I had
like a bunch of like I was just an
egotistical kid my best friend died that
year like a bunch of crazy [__] happened
and then like some of it for sure was
like feeling like imposter is you know
like oh man I'm going to go and I'm
going to get [__] dunked on I'm going
to look like an idiot like I'm actually
not that good like fear of failure all
tied in which you don't know when you're
17 but that would have changed like
trajectories like not that I'd be LeBron
James but I could be playing in Europe I
could be I could could have gone to a
division one school instead of junior
college cuz some people wish they had a
r it was like the Wily Wonka ticket for
basketball sure can you backwards dunk
no that was never there no no I was not
bro can you do a one hand Jordan from
Theo line no okay that's hop no I'm like
I'm slip I'm 5'9 Italian I'm slipping
them over the r what about off the back
where 360 can you do that oh 95 I could
probably do a barbell right now all
right in terms of your play style what
would be like a similar NBA like Jau or
I was a Jason kid Steve Nash no way yeah
yeah I I led the nation in assists
that's tight yeah my senior year yeah
yeah sick yeah that's pretty [__]
cool yeah we're in it that was
definitely a Willy Wonka ticket you just
burned up yeah burned it yeah that was
all that's like literally your question
opportunity I [__] what was the first
year or first time you had a chance to
even look back at and go damn I [__]
that one up like the next day probably
the next year cuz then I'm at Junior
College and I was really lucky to have a
good coach and he's like so good about
like team building and like just hard
work and work I think like he's just
philosophically so good so then I go to
Junior College in Vallejo if you guys
know where that is not a great place and
like everyone's just there for
themselves everyone's like Knuck head
they're all right in yeah no bro I'm a
team player oh let Nation assists thanks
Steve got it well he just said he was a
knucklehead and egotistic I was but like
not with the team like more just
internally just being a teenager you
know so like even that year is when I
quit uh and I just kind of knew like man
I I chose the wrong direction I'd rather
be the worst player like I had
opportunities to play Same Mar's which
is really good at the time and I would
have sat at the bench but I would have
been like in March Madness sitting the
bench wow you know what I mean like they
made it to the Sweet 16 and I would have
sat at the end of the bench high five
and handed towels but it would have been
[__] dope Duke is the best basketball
program in the world University of
Kansas probably University of Kansas is
probably historically always top five
though yeah but Duke's always their
their coach did just retire who was like
the most epic coach of all time but
they're they're top yeah Coach K yeah I
don't know [__] about him just yeah top
five they're they're definitely top five
more epic than John Wood no no maybe
John Wood and Coach K are the best of
all time oh I see hands down so like not
for this to be like a super depressing
video and stuff like that but what's the
Silver Lining that you feel you got out
of not going to the Willy Wonka golden
ticket not getting your dream probably
like probably like the taking more
opportunities like all right I'll show
up and suck like even the first time
like Bart brought me here like I knew
yall's channel was huge first time I was
here Joe what 2013 no huge was huge
biggest channel in the game I'm saying
what I was but I had like no YouTube I
didn't have my YouTube channel and I'm
2013 we just kind of lifted weights a
couple times he's like hey you want to
come I'm like oh [__] you've been here
way before 2013 maybe 2012 that's way
before yeah that's a long time ago but
same idea I was nervous as [__] I was
probably 23 years old like damn I don't
even know what YouTube is like we were
doing Fitness content but no one cared
about that like you guys were legitimate
YouTube and I was like all right well
here we go and I was just like all right
[__] it I'll show up stuff like that I'm
a pretty shy dude to begin with I'm
comfortable with y'all cuz I know y'all
but that's why your name is silent mic
yeah literal even though you're like
pretty loud in the once you know me yeah
you're
[__] hey thank you for sharing thanks
class thanks thanks and now you got a
popcorn somebody I don't know what that
oh who's next
yeah I remember popcorn class what's
that mean you say popcorn and then the
next person popcorn I didn't even think
I didn't even think about Mone I don't
think we had popcorn dude that I thought
you would live a life of a lot of
regrets for me yeah why that's a [__]
stab that is why but it's kind of good
cuz Nick has a forlorn look on his face
of all times for La as if he's sitting
on a dock looking on in the Horizon and
he's like Ah that's where that's the
that's the Catalyst of his pessimism
because I [__] that up and I [__] this
up and I [__] that no that's that's kind
of true though I feel like that a lot
yeah in a lot of ways this is serious
but as far as like I want to say
opportunity man but when I started
fighting I thought that was I really
thought I was going to do something with
that as far as like going pro and I was
like a big dream of mine but like uh
when I started getting those concussions
I just was like dude I'm [__] I just
kept telling myself like [__] dude I'm
not built for this I can't do this but
that's a smart move that's yeah no 100%
but as far as like what my heart wanted
at the time and what like my mindset and
now I'm like dude it was kind of a good
opportunity I'm so glad that that
happened to me cuz you know what
fighting is great and it's cool but it's
definitely not there's so many different
ways to make money you know and at that
time like it was definitely a passion
but I think it it just forced me to be
creative with uh what I did with my life
afterwards like I didn't think I I just
kept following things that I like doing
like coaching and just working with
people and I think that was just better
for me for the sake of the prompt was
there something that was specifically
like what you would consider the best
opportunity that you received in that I
I think I think when I when I left my
the gym that I was at for like 10 years
that was like the opportunity for me
where I was like oh [__] there's like
the world just seemed like it got bigger
and it was like a forced opportunity it
was more of like they kick you out no
well not really no what's your
opportunity I got kicked out my kind of
though no it wasn't it wasn't like I got
kicked out it was just more of like my
time here is done I think did you did
you come to that understanding because
like a something else was offered to you
no it was more of like me realizing that
like it hit a wall yeah there's nothing
here and and and it forced me to create
a new opportunity that I didn't think I
could ever do like I thought everything
my whole life was in that gym everybody
I knew was in that gym my family like I
I looked at it as like my my family uh
like my main family and then when I left
I was like I was like super scared I was
like [__] kind of depressed a little
bit and just like not knowing what the
[__] was going to happen and I didn't
know if I had the ability to like make a
living once I left that place uh and as
far as like my community was was all
tied in there so when I left I was like
just really scared and um just unsure
about the future but I think that
opportunity forced me to to create new
ones for myself you know yeah you have
brought that story up before and that
feels like a very [__] pivotal moment
of your journey that's big how old were
you then like 25 okay so not even that
long AG actually no not even I was I was
I was older I was like 27 20 25 27 so
like last week yeah yeah basically sick
but now I'm like now what the [__] am I
going to do that's the silver lightning
I wake up every day thinking that though
yeah no but but it's fine cuz you you
realize like okay I did it before I
could do it again World opened yeah the
World opened up a lot it was a lot
bigger for me cuz I was very insulated I
think was it money based it was money
based cuz I never once thought about how
I was going to make money as an adult as
a kid or just even now yeah well that a
privileged mindset no I'm a lucky dude
for sure like I do make money like
you've been obviously I work but like
I've never been like oh I'm going to be
a lawyer or whatever like all I knew is
I loved basketball and then all I know
now is like all right well I you were
interest based I do this yeah kind of
like well I kind of know how to do this
I hope you're reincarnated into an Asian
family when you get reborn I don't know
how you probably don't do things that's
risky to get you in situations where
you're like oh I need money now yeah
yeah yeah but you feel that like you
feel your back against the wall and you
just feel like hey just go that that
anxiety is like oh what the [__] am I
going to do you're waking up in the
middle of the night like freaking the
[__] out having panic attacks and then
you realize like oh yeah you're tripping
about [__] not like in the grand
scheme things it's not that big of a
deal it doesn't matter what up guys this
episode of off the Record is brought to
you by Factor meals I know we are all
busy in this day and age we all got
things to do we got school work trying
to work out trying to spend time with
all of our relationships our families so
a lot of times food is the last thing
that is on your mind but we all have to
eat which is why I love Factor meals
because they are flavorful meals and
healthy delivered straight to your door
and there's a bunch of different options
calorie smart veggie vegan Protein Plus
so no matter what your goals are you can
find a meal that's going to help you and
all of these are delicious dietician
approved meals meaning they're
professionally put together to make sure
they hit specific caloric requirements
all while tasting amazing head to factor
meals.com off thc50 and use the code off
thee record 50 to get 50% off that's off
thec 50 at Factor meals.com off thc50 to
get 50% off get fed get some flavor and
stay healthy how we've been broke is
different than like broke like I know if
my world explodes I can sleep on Bart's
couch I can sleep on my mom's couch you
know what I mean that kind of makes me
feel couch too right you know what I
mean like that kind of gives me
confidence to kind of just [__] around
did you just skim over the fact that you
have panic attacks yeah but I think
that's normal I think everyone has that
[__] I don't think so how many do you
get well at that time I would just like
I would just like freaking the [__] out
cuz it was it was it was just everything
I do with ears like you saying that a
little scary
bro no but like you know I would I would
just be just
super I'd wake up in the middle of night
just like cold hot sweats yeah that no
no not everybody I've been there but not
everybody does that yeah that's think
been there but at a time of high stress
in a time where you just everything's
uncertain I think that is normal like I
think that does happen it does happen so
how' you get past the panic attack just
suck it up dude you suck it up and you
just [__] that's inspiration pulling
Bo bootstraps but but no no not just
your bootstraps but I feel like packs
for him when you feel like that's your
means of survival and then that's I
don't want to say taken away from you it
just force it just puts fire under your
ass and it makes you move for I like it
that's the fighter we know you take you
take a deep breath and then you go oh
I'm up it's 3:00 a.m. let me do the
[__] emails cuz I'm afraid about
money and then this is going to get me
money yeah or or you just go okay I'm
[__] up I'm going to go back to sleep
tomorrow but tomorrow I'm going to
[__] get all the [__] done I need to
get done or whatever I don't like Panic
ta I don't either I used to have them so
much in waking up just wake up like 3:
in the morning 400 in the morning like
something's chasing you like yeah like
what the [__] like just feeling having
like weird dreams about [__] you know
well it's only bad when you wake up and
it's still bad oh boy right like in
those situations like you're actually
broke or something's bad and you wake up
you're like oh [__] it's real cuz you do
that with a nightmare and then you're
like oh that was a vampire I get
nightmares yeah yeah that's scary but
when you wake up and you're like [__]
the problem's still there that's not but
also in the grand scheme things too like
I I was still living at home like I
didn't really have like it it was I was
fine it was just my own [__] that I
created in my own head so it's like well
I mean that's real for you yeah
definitely definitely but I think it
made me better for it like it taught me
how to be more of a man and less of a
boy I think hey you almost said woman
huh I'm a little bit of a woman D I
think we that's okay little um yeah
what's up popcorn somebody huh uh
Anthony Lee what about you you got to
say popcorn and then popcorn you Anthony
Lee oh man all
right lost opportunities no it wasn't it
could be a good one it could be I
started negative yeah it supposed to be
a good one I literally said what was the
best opportunity this this has been a
dark video yeah my
bad
female what uh last opportunity best
opportunity best opportunity I just
heard opportunity oh yeah it was the
best opportunity that I [__] up I just
happened to [__] no it was yeah Wily I
was right lost opportunities it just
went it was really good no but the it's
we're going for the best opportunity was
the best opportunity you received even
if you burned it and threw it away and
regret it for the rest of your life and
I think opportunity maybe people think
different when I think opportunity I
think like luck in a sense like it just
it happens to like to you like I didn't
do it it happens for you cuz yeah yeah
other good things happen that I like
made happen yeah you know what I mean so
much but that's still an opportunity a
lot of work like I [__] built that
[__] but that one just kind of happened
for me well they all they all working
the same cuz even like getting a a
promotion at your job is an opportunity
but you earned that right let talk about
the definition for the rest of the
video popcorn Steve yeah hit his ass you
got to go you got to go you got to go I
popcorn you you got to respect my
popcorn this whole conversation no you
got to give your example best
opportunity that you [__]
squandered that was not the prompt Brew
down the drain okay well I had a I had a
an answer for the first prompt but
squandered is different oh just go back
to we want you to win yeah we want you
to win hurry up all right first thing
that comes to mind actually is when uh I
got booked to be the choreographer for a
Chinese TV show called Hot blood Dance
Crew it was a dance reality competition
and then uh preas during kjas during
kjas this is like 2015 or some [__] like
that and this is actually the event
where I met both both Luhan and Jackson
went guys that I've talked about on the
show they're like Superstars Mike in
China yeah like Justin Bieber level
right yeah super huge um musicians
artists artists yeah but they also danc
cuz they were part of like K-pop groups
and stuff like that and then they they
broke out and did their own like solo
careers and stuff and got like super
huge and whatnot Chris Breezy types yeah
more like JT typ beating [__] and
more like like take leaving NC making
your whole career I'm a big JT fan yeah
and then uh from there because I went on
that show I was a choreographer I was
actually supposed there's two dance
teams that go like head-to-head and then
they were the captains of one team with
like other dancers and then there's
these two other artists and I was
supposed to be these two artist
choreographers but they're losers no I
won't say that they're more like Back
Street Boys they're just different
flavor right uh one of them uh is a
chick the other one uh just is not my
flavor did you know these people as you
go in I kind of knew of these two I
didn't really know these two but I've
heard of them and I came in I was
supposed to be their choreographer
because the choreographer that was
supposed to be for these two had worked
with one of them before already so there
was already a relationship right so we
all brought our teams I brought some
other kindas with me this guy brought
some of his like dance with him and then
we go there and then the first episode
is all four of them work with a
different choreographer just to do
initial showcase the artists before like
the dancers come in as a team and we
were the choreographers and then I
remember watching and then like uh super
amazing but like gay dude was
choreographing for the chick over here
and then the other dude did this other
collab and these two did some badass
hip-hop routines with these other two
like guest choreographers and I remember
being like man that's our flavor I don't
know how I'm going to work with this so
I went slide and I went back to the
producers and I was like hey I think you
guys should switch the choreographers
for these two teams because if you think
about it this group and what who they
brought is going to work really well mes
with this talent and then I think what
we do in our specifics are going to
match really well with this so if you
want a really bomb show that that brings
out the best I think we should switch
and it worked but the crazy thing is we
won that show after we switched we ended
up going through that season and winning
that show and since then I've worked
with those guys every single year up
until this day one of those guys I just
finished the tour with in China this
past year the other guy joined our crew
and we're like super super close homies
I have a matching tattoo with the guy
just did the tour with I have a matching
tattoo with the other dude and we like
so this is not that special not that
special not that special wow who else
you have a match have to with you Nick
big deal whatever whatever ours ours is
bigger but that sounded like you made
the opp Happ it sounds like you pulled
some
strings and then you gave yourself hey I
received the opportunity and I did my
best with it it's awesome but it I I
never would have thought one we' win and
two we would actually go on to become
hella good friends and continue working
every cuz a lot of people get presented
an opportunity and they don't optimize
it they just take it for face value you
got something and you somehow made it
even better yeah were you nervous doing
that that kind of [__] makes me nervous
I wasn't I don't think nerv like to
bring up that conversation to bring that
up right here yeah no no no no there
like hey man I need to work with that
dude and to make that happen make to be
completely honest I feel like that's one
of my random skill sets to do that in
the back you know what I mean like more
than just being a talented individual
that can get the job done I feel like
figuring out what the right job to do is
is one of my things doing it in the back
cuz your yeah getting it done to me in
the back the getting it from the back
getting it hard in the back yeah popcorn
and Steve while we still got twoes okay
easy no problem um which time right so
my whole life is about being early to
things I think like I um in 200 [__]
8 but you're late to JK all the time but
and so is
he but no being being early to like you
know like like YouTube when it was first
coming up right like I had just come
from improv and I was like I don't know
how like I'm trying to get into the like
the actor business stuff and I was like
I don't know how that's going to work
out but I I met a bunch of people like
doing tubes early days and so I just
kind of like found myself in with like
some of the biggest people on YouTube
like really early because nobody like
really knew about YouTube back then and
so um yeah I'm like working with like
all these big tubers and they offer to
hire me they're like hey come work for
us like Studio yeah we need a writer
like come work for us and I was like I
was like you know what [__] it my
girlfriend's dad at the time he's like
you'll never make money writing ever cuz
he was a a failed actor oh [__] bitter
as [__] yeah about it so he's you'll
never make money writing in Hollywood
and [__] and so he's the first
[__] I call when I got that gig
right took about the dinner I wasn't
making much I wasn't making much right
but I was I was like you got a job this
my job [__] deal with it suck my
dick all right so then um nice yeah so
I'm early the tubes and then I remember
I was tubing it and tubing it right and
um helping all these tubers write their
shitty ass content right and it's
garbage stuff right real trash stuff
we're putting out there and um and then
um I got in with all these really cool
people I met CM I met hron I met like
you know Mike Gallagher all these people
that I've been working with forever and
then um you know couple years into that
they they were like hey we want you to
just come on here fulltime no more
making stuff for your channel just work
for us and I was like [__] you I'm doing
my own channel I'm betting on myself so
I was like give me Fridays give me
Fridays on Friday I'm going to go film
with my crew and like I'll be yours from
Monday to Thursday and they're like fine
and so every Friday I would just go and
like get George camel and like we would
just go to the [__] um Venice
boardwalk and I'd just figure out what
I'm going to do the night before and
then I was doing that and doing that and
finally it just it took a long time dude
I was probably getting like I don't know
I was getting like no views on my videos
couple thousand right and then all of a
sudden it just started to click it just
started to hit started like uploading
every time I uploaded I got a million
views eventually and that was like
insane and then during that I was like
okay this is scary unsustainable as [__]
there's no way I'm going to get a
million views every time I upload what
am I going to do next how do I pivot
into the next thing so then I started
writing movies me and Mike were writing
movies like at his place for free
nobody's paying us we're just doing it
we're writing movies on spec and we just
kept on writing movies we wrote like
[__] I don't even know how many
movies right and then got lucky there
like we're you know using parlaying
tuber shittiness with meeting Hollywood
people they were interested in our
numbers right so like we don't care
what's on your stupid script give us the
numbers and so then that's when I sold
my movie internet famous right and they
were like cool who's going to be it and
I'm like me [__] you know what I
mean like [__] like that just like
stepping out and being like I it's me
and then like being like did that work
and they're like sure okay and I'm like
who that worked holy [__]
and then during that even I was like
okay I was like remember my mom was
visiting me one time and she's like
stepen there's no plan there's no plan
Stephen he's like when she's like when
when Grandma goes like your dad's idea
she starts crying she's like your dad's
ideas we're going to move into a Motel 6
Stephen and I was like [__] I got to
figure a way I got to figure a way to
make sure that my m is not going have to
worry about money and then I was like oh
yeah I bought this thing called Bitcoin
in 2013 I was like wonder what like the
newest shit's going on with crypto stuff
so then I found ethereum when it was
like [__] five bucks and [__] right
and I was like dang I really think this
is sick so I I put like probably 15K
into it back then and that was like
[__] maybe the move of my life right
like unbelievable that was like that was
like 3 months before it broke out and
like went to [__] like insane amounts
right then I got a little bit wrecked
there
right got a little got a little wrecked
um parlay into another crypto from
ethereum should have probably just kept
my ethereum stack had a big old boy
stack right f um then I was in this
other crypto right called OMG we were
riding we rode it um that was the first
time we made it Mill that was it it was
the first time we made just to about a
Mill and hold on to too much then yeah
we learned to not hold for too long
right then we got wrecked on that one
for a little while but then hey we kept
buying the lows we were smart we kept
buying those lows up right Scoopy Scoopy
Scoopy season so so then you know sure
enough we go into snx we get into well
first of all OMG comes back then we get
into snx then we get into like [__]
Luna and [__] we ride that [__]
to $1.2 million from a $28,000
investment that was fun quite a ride you
were at what 35 uh I started 110k and I
went to 1.6 million but when it when it
came back after 1 point oh no no no when
it came back you what was your lowest
amount you at like 110k oh uh at at I
was under that yeah under like $60,000
60,000 right into 1.6 that was fun so
then now here we are right the precipice
the dawn is coming right been been
scooping and Scoopy in for [__] 20
months right now right and you feel the
same energy oh buddy I got I'm dialed in
you're tingling I can feel it I can feel
it I'm ready I'm dialed into the [__]
game dude get ready cuz I'm about to
blow everyone's [__] mind again we're
going to do it again that's what I say
at the end of every one of my crypto
Corner episodes we are going to do it
again Watch What Happens Next and we're
wooing we're wooing and we're cooing
baby coochi kuira that's his baby yeah
two of them you're sponsored no I'm not
sponsored I make this [__] myself I
don't take a dime from these
[__] yeah he made that necklace
he made the Hat he made everything yep I
wonder when they're going to send a ceas
and toist I got woo shoes on no dude
they love me they got he's got woo socks
on
we're going to do it again crypto Corner
baby that's dedication that's
opportunity that's making opportunity
damnn right always I'm always early
maybe I get wrecked for a little while
but I I'm always on to the next one
we'll do we'll redo this prompt in a
couple months dude and all our story is
going to be about woo be fun give be a
ride give be a
ride I got to buy more woo I need some
[Music]
woo
St